[Applause]
today everybody I am so excited Mike
Pompeo is here tonight
[Applause]
wow we even get a little USA chant there
a lot of guys in suits around here
looking at me eyeballing me so you know
what that means an entire a block on
Harry Potter
Mike said do it or he'd walk who knew
Pompeo was a hairy pothead
although I did overhear him talking
about his Hogwarts
so next month there's a new game coming
out called Hogwarts Legacy
now for all you non-dorks dweebs nerds
and men who have never touched a woman
who wasn't a relative
the game is set in the World of Harry
Potter and it seems like fun but
according to the outrage who are always
outraged if you buy this game you are a
bigoted monster see for the past year
trans activists have been pushing a
boycott of the game over its association
with author J.K Rowling of course she's
got nothing to do with making the game
at all women don't know computers
oh sexist would say
of course she'll profit from the
licensing rights which has certain
pro-trans groups boiling mad but they've
been that way for years she was absent
from the Harry Potter film's 20th
anniversary special fan sites have
stopped covering her in One gaming site
even banned mention of the new game
entirely essentially proving what she
suggested about the trans movement
they're better at deleting women than
Ted Bundy but what is her actual crime
Beyond forcing me to do a monologue on
Harry Potter
well once she retweeted an op-ed piece
that talked about people who menstruate
that's right it was a period piece
well done thank you all done but
rallying there correctly pointed out
that the actual word for this is women
and after the shrieking subsided she
wrote in a follow-up quote if sex isn't
real there's no same-sex attraction if
sex isn't real the lived reality of
women globally is erased I know and love
trans people but erasing the concept of
sex removes the ability of many to
meaningfully discuss their lives it
isn't hate to speak the truth and that
is true she also echoed a concern that
we here to have warned about many myself
included believe we are watching a new
kind of conversion therapy for young gay
people who are being set on a lifelong
path of medicalization that may result
in the loss of their fertility and or
full sexual function so the only winners
here are whack job therapists surgical
butchers and big Pharma which sounds
like three bands I might like
and for that she's been targeted
threatened and banned activists says
she's a bigot who's using her Fame to
hurt trans people and that she's
contributed to anti-trans rhetoric but
it's hard to find evidence of that
anywhere I haven't seen any videos where
someone sneaks up behind a trans person
and strangles them with piano wire and
Whispers JK Rowling says hello I haven't
seen anything like that and I watch a
lot of Fox and Friends
that's where I get all my news meanwhile
rallying has stood her ground last year
someone asked her how she sleeps at
night knowing she's lost an audience she
replied I read my most recent royalty
checks
I know if only Jesse Waters could say
the same about his book
[Laughter]
anyway this video game is going to sell
millions of course but the reason we're
talking about it is this fake boycott
not only has she not done anything wrong
she's nothing compared to those who have
done real wrong yet still have Legions
of support how about Michael Jackson you
know the guy with a ferris wheel in his
backyard now I'm no detective but that
should have been a red flag
that guy's music is still played
everywhere hell I was dancing to it in
front of my bedroom window last night
until the cops arrived and made me put
on a robe
same for Kudlow too
how about all the movies Harvey
Weinstein produced you're gonna skip
Pulp Fiction the next time you're
flipping through the channels because
that movie and many other great ones
would never been made without that
scumbag seen there or how about
Rosemary's Baby or Chinatown directed by
none other than Roman Polanski and how
about Chuck Berry
Google it if you want to find out what
he did let's just say Johnny wasn't
being good in the John
so not only are the attacks on rallying
a joke their Solutions worse for if you
were to boycott every product that could
be traced to some perceived problematic
stance what would you have left you
couldn't go to the movies you couldn't
read novels you couldn't watch TV all
you'd have left are books by Dana Perino
and those things are filthy
periods welcome
tonight's guest he can't talk to
terrorists mostly because he had them
all killed former Secretary of State and
author of the great new book never give
an inch Mike Pompeo
sees the anchor with the ranker Fox News
anchor Julie Bandera
she's got a lot of fans mostly because
she sweats Fox News contributor Kat Tim
and he uses the Great Wall of China for
calf raises my master sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
do you know do I call you Mr secretary
no Mike please Mike yes Mr secretary's
more fun though go go with it but I
think I'm going to need Mike to get me
out of here tonight
anyway let's get right to it who killed
JFK
[Laughter]
somebody watches the show Absolutely he
watches the show are you a Harry Potter
fan uh no I don't have any Harry Potter
at my house because there's nothing
classified in it no that's right
are you worried have you been going
through your stuff I I as soon as I get
out of here yes exactly we're going to
do that in the next block by the way so
what do you think about this idea of
boycotting things and and uh and this
whole movement against it seems kind of
bizarre that she's become the the focal
point for all this yeah like we've all
seen this before where someone says
something uh the left the progressive
book left kind of picks it up yeah and
then they they try to just use economics
to drive more it's crazy stuff
um a lot of folks want to read her stuff
people should read her stuff and frankly
what she said is pretty accurate we
pretty confident there's just two
genders and most of the babies are had
by women yeah that is true that is true
you know that's a joke all of them
by the way I'm just chapter 13. it is
true there are aliens and they live
among us
wow that's uh that's pretty powerful
I've just made that up I just made that
up I like doing that oh I'm reading it
yes I thought I thought I took that part
out yes exactly it's been redacted so
Julie um your kids read Harry Potter no
no we're not a Harry Potter family I
never quite understood the fascination
of it but if my kids are going to play a
video game I don't think that the author
or the creator of that video game is
going to make a difference as to whether
I think they should be playing the video
game but I got to give it to JK
um in 2020 she posted a series of tweets
arguing that transgender women should
not be counted as women and this is a
quote if sex isn't real the lived
reality of women globally is erased
finally a woman who agrees with me that
sex isn't real
I always heard about it I think you got
it backwards
I'm saying it is real I know she is but
wait I'm just talking about let's go
with this
not real and we're not bad at it yeah
that is true well at least that's what
his wife says it's just going are you
regretting we're just the fastest regret
that you've ever had to I am pretty sure
I know why you have Secretary of State
on before I think I just figured it out
he's going to make a code red call yes
yeah I find it ironic that your title is
called never give an inch and yet you've
given away how many 20 inches a couple
yeah yeah see the weight loss connection
this is why I'm sitting here and those
other people are one of the theories yes
yeah and the pictures cat um you know
this are you a fan of JK Rowling you're
a weird kid you probably were 20 years
ago like reading those books that's why
it's so weird to me that JK Rowling is
this conservative icon now because my
mom wouldn't let me read Harry Potter
because Witchcraft and Wizardry were of
the devil yeah exactly I'm completely
serious imagine how easy it was for me
to fit in and
but now like in you know now she's the
insert of Icon because like the devil I
feel like I have heard is not
conservative like he's more of a bad boy
yeah
um but it's just all kind of flipped now
and that's why it's super super
interesting to me but Harry Potter I
some of the quotes in this article I
could not handle like it was like lgbtq
community roiling over Harry Potter
video game I don't think that's true no
I can't no I always wonder that's true
some of the quotes in the article people
are like so and like they're calling it
a crisis I'm like but if you think
that's a crisis like boy do I have some
stories for you yeah yes it must be nice
to have a life where this is the biggest
problem that you have that people don't
have exactly in your family you're not
suffering from any debilitating issues
you're allowed to read Harry Potter yeah
exactly exactly how many of these
outraged people are actually outraged or
is this an attention-seeking device for
Trump well their definition of outrage
this was probably originally they
thought this would be a good Shakedown
they'd come to her and she would donate
all kinds of money to their fund and
their cause and when she didn't oh well
now we'll cancel you because first of
all she's gangster JK I didn't read
Harry Potter but I'm buying all the
books I'm getting paper bag hardcover if
there's an audio I'm in it you know the
video game didn't look with my speed
downloaded it today on my Xbox so I'm
all in a thousand percent why don't
really care for the books and the fact
that she was just being a normal adult
woman defending herself and defending
feminism and being successful is not a
crime yeah they try to invent these
crimes to take us down and I'm glad the
kids are going to keep buying the book
the people who none of them are buying
the book yeah like that's the thing like
they're not won't go broke you how many
woke movies did you see this year when
it came out I'll tell you none yeah they
all failed miserably the new woke
Scooby-Doo the worst cartoon debut in
the history of cartoons that means they
lost to when the guy took a piece of
paper it went like this yeah you saw the
guy running
beat the whoa that's great is that
Thomas Edison
[Laughter]
Hocus Pocus kiss her ass and enjoy your
royalty checks ma that is yeah that's so
true
Thelma yeah is it called Thelma the new
Scooby-Doo nobody knows what it's called
because nobody saw that yeah it's Thelma
oh I know what it's called canceled
Thelma yeah all right the guy told me I
knew that I didn't care yes he was uh
yeah he went on sarcasm hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else